Una vez que has mirado la lengua y has
visto estas marcas de dientes en los
bordes como si estuviese mordida. Porque
esto que estás viendo ahora mismo se
llama lengua indentada. Y aunque mucha
gente piensa que es normal, a veces
puede ser una señal de que algo no está
funcionando bien. Fíjate en esta lengua.
¿Ves como los laterales tienen la forma
exacta de los dientes? Esto ocurre
porque la lengua está constantemente
presionando contra ellos. ¿Y por qué
pasa esto? Pues la causa más frecuente
suele ser la inflamación o aumento de
tamaño de la lengua y muchas veces
también está relacionado con el
bruxismo. Sí, apretar o rechinar los
dientes mientras duermes. Cuando
aprietas fuerte, la lengua queda
atrapada constantemente contra los
dientes y acaba marcándose así. Pero no
es la única causa. También puede
aparecer en personas con estrés y
ansiedad, en gente que respira por la
boca, en problemas de sueño como las
apneas, en alteraciones de la mordida
donde los dientes ocupen el espacio que
debería tener la lengua o incluso por
deshidratación o déficit nutricionales.
Y aquí viene lo importante. La lengua
muchas veces es un espejo de lo que está
pasando en tu cuerpo, porque no solo
miramos dientes, los dentistas miramos
músculos, respiración, desgaste, postura
de la lengua, saliva, tejidos y muchas
veces detectamos problemas antes de que
el paciente sea consciente. Ahora bien,
tener una lengua intentada no significa
automáticamente que tengas un problema
grave, pero si además notas cansancio,
ronquidos, dolor mandibular, dolores de
cabeza al despertar, desgaste dental o
sensación de tensión en la cara, quizá
tu boca está intentando decirte algo y
probablemente llevas años viéndolo en el
espejo sin saber lo que significaba. Ab.